hey guys welcome to the Thanksgiving
edition of the Reuben report I'm the
chief turkey dave rubin I've got a
beanie k williams and Rick Grinnell its
Richard Grinnell on Twitter but you said
call me Rick coming all my friends on
the race if you want to be we are
friends and it's ebony k would not just
ebony Williams I'm putting the K in
there yes ya ain't have any Williams on
Twitter know what I wanted to keep to
keep that way yeah it seven EK ebony k
alright very good well it is
Thanksgiving I think when we're putting
these clips of it is actually
Thanksgiving so let's start with some
thanksgiving stuff so organizing for
action which is President Obama's super
PAC they sent out an email this week
telling people that they should talk
about Obamacare at the Thanksgiving
table because there's nothing better
than talking politics and policy during
thanksgiving and not only did they send
an email but there was a link to a
website which would guide you because
you're the voice of reason that's what
they told you you're the voice of reason
in your family and they give you a
little guide to how you should go about
doing it so they give you some
conversation tips you can start by
asking have you thought about signing up
for health insurance on the new
marketplace grandma offer to walk them
through it would you like to take some
time with me to sign up right now ask
them to make a plan and commit to it
when do you plan on signing up don't
forget to follow up have you signed up
yet and some things that are important
to communicate being covered helps you
stay healthy and protects you in an
emergency you can find a plan that fits
your budget financial assistance is
available for all those who qualify and
you get to choose the plan that's right
for you period they should have put a
period in there okay just easy questions
to start is there anything worse than
talking politics with your family at
thanksgiving look I think it's it really
unfortunately is telling of just how
much of a struggle they're having with
messaging so now they're having to send
this thing out for like a holiday
special really like come on it's not not
a good look yeah I do plan on talking
Obamacare at the Thanksgiving table I
probably would but my first question
would be are you willing to pay higher
premiums for the same coverage I mean
on that show let's be clear I actually
think this is a great idea I think this
is the exact reason why the Obama
re-election team did so well and why he
was re-elected they're very creative why
not put forward some talking points to
encourage people they've got a lot of
people who are sheep they got a lot of
people who just follow the directions
and start these conversations at the
dinner table the fact is people don't
know about this process because the
website is crappy and the messaging is
terrible but I think this is a very
creative way lame but creative yeah well
all right well speaking of lame let's
take a look there was also a video that
they created and it's like a two minute
long video they think it's really
hilarious but it's actually quite lame
this is just the end of it so what did
you want to talk to me about we know you
don't have health insurance we love you
no matter what but it's time to get
covered that's it health insurance it's
important I know and I'll do it I just
thought never mind
yeah something very pandering and season
there something sort of insulting about
that I cookie that's what I'm saying to
me it's it's insulting but I i do get
Rick's point in that this is what they
do and this is what they do well I will
say I'm surprised to see it being the
parents initiating the talk with the Sun
because we all know Obama strongpoint
tends to be the youth and so I would
have almost expected the kid to bring it
up to kind of spread the message amongst
the older generation remember this is
the group that gave us binders full of
women I mean we're talking really lame a
messaging that doesn't make sense but
again it works I mean I think this war
on women thing is crap but it works and
people just hear that basic stuff it's
catchy and this is the same thing yeah
so just to the bigger idea of Obamacare
at this point I mean this obviously
shows some level of desperation that
they have to give out such specific
messaging and all that kinda stuff and
also get involved in holidays you're
supposed to be thankful I feel like it's
the one day where I try not to talk
about politics do you think this thing's
going to turn around by the by the end
of the year because i'm still looking
like a disaster no and I was so
frustrated guys to see him put another
deadline for himself when clearly that's
not something that you guys are doing
well I'm meeting a deadline so that's
what I don't know whose idea that was
what that person needs to be fired but
yeah no I don't think it's going to turn
around any time before the end of the
year so speaking of getting fired one of
every story that we've done on this on
this show I keep saying someone has to
get fine yes fire somebody someone an IT
guy the guy who is testifying that we
are we eighty percent of it wasn't even
made fire somebody the janitor how come
no one ever gets fired well look we r 5
years into the obama administration and
there have been a lot of things that
have gone wrong but we just don't fire
people in government that's the union
way you don't fire people you just
reassign them and i think it's terrible
i think in the private sector you are
gone immediately and then they you know
announce that you're going to spend more
time with your family so the simple fact
is that if they did this I think then
they would have better people coming in
because people would be feared it would
be fearful that they're gonna get fired
I agree that even if somebody who tends
to lean left I agree with you a hundred
percent Rick I think that's the problem
with government and that's a problem a
lot of people feel about it there's no
consequences when you mess up
and when people don't have an incentive
such as keeping your job for doing it
well why are you doing it well so yeah
it's the no-brainer to me so it's part
of the things they don't fire them
because if you fired one person you'd
have to fire a ton of people like it
would sort of like it's like the string
that would unleash the whole really not
so I i was in government for a long time
and i had a team of 11 people that
worked for me and there was one
individual who was not doing her job
having alcohol problems sleeping at her
desk and i set out with HR to try to
figure out okay how do we get rid of
this person they're clearly not working
and I was told absolutely you cannot get
rid of them you have to deal with them
send them to counseling talk to them
we're not getting rid of them you have
to deal and so as a boss you just
reassign them yeah I can't get one of
those jobs but nobody can drink during
the day nobody wins and even like
somebody like you know the teachers
unions and stuff and I love teachers I
went to public school they're amazing
but I had classes where I'm like is this
serious you know seriously you know
you're wasting my time all these
students those teachers gotta go so I
mean that's a little bit of an edge
reform issue but it works in every
sector yeah it does you're right yeah
well we took a Thanksgiving segment and
turned it into something about how more
people should be fired pretty like that
all right let's let's move on but stick
with Thanksgiving for a little bit so
black friday which has become somehow
more important than thanksgiving itself
of course this is the day after
thanksgiving when every store on earth
has sales that you will not believe in
you can get a flat screen TV for like 25
bucks and that whole thing but of course
there is a price pay and there are many
videos on youtube that prove it
Oh
I mean that's America because I love
America I am sure that is America that's
why we went with it it looks like it's
at a World War Z is this just
consumerism run rampant I have a
terrible economy Dave I mean come on
these guy they're trying to get a flat
screen TV for twenty-five dollars when
they're out of work but do you think
come on but they even if it was a good
economy people love this stuff for some
reason to i think it's great i think
commercialism is fine look I'm all force
pushing the season having these stores
open on Thanksgiving Day I don't buy any
of this phony stuff that if you're not
you know closed on Thanksgiving Day
you're not pro-family baloney a lot of
people eat in the morning they want to
shop in the afternoon yeah when I say
yeah my mom and I that's our thing like
you know that's our bonding we don't
have the big traditional family it's
just the two of us we eat we we show our
thanks and then we bond family oriented
style through shopping do you do it on
thanksgiving cuz now just in the last
couple your stores are actually starting
to open on thanksgiving too it's not
just unwrapped toy store isn't open on
Thanksgiving I'm like you know you
forget something on the way to a
friend's house for or family dinner you
want to buy something you get bored
after four hours i'm not a football guy
night sit around watch football i want
to go out and shop and get some stuff
done I'm a Virgo right I left I'm a
little sad about that guys as I've also
worked in retail and and that's I hate
it for the people that are working don't
want to be at work and then they don't
have an option that that does suck oh
yeah oh stop but i forked retailing have
to work on days that i didn't want to
work at work your way out of retail know
what you're doing now I mean this
message to people they are giving you
work you work hard in retail you'll get
a different job I don't look come on
this is America you get to work if
you're working for jobs and one happens
to be on Thanksgiving you're getting
paid but isn't there something to be
said for just having a national day off
like I get it you want to shop and you
want to do that it's nice to keep the
economy going on but just to have a day
just two days a year maybe thanksgiving
christmas that's it we're pretty much
everything is just shut down and we can
stop this endless i guess so but at the
same time I feel like it's about choice
and it's about options you know and it's
like you know we're both saying for some
people that's their bonding I know for
all my family thanks Thanksgiving
and Christmas Day we do shopping and we
do movies so thank goodness somebody's
you know working the ticket booth yeah
jus movie in Chinese that's how to see
work yeah we're helping the economy in
another dealing this bodes poorly when
people in other countries see this kind
of thing cuz I is there any other
country that a day of riots for all
kinds of other reasons probably much
more legitimate reasons but does this
make us look EE stupid then because then
they're like look at those Americans
when they have riots it's because they
want to get you know a microwave at half
price no I think they're jealous I think
they look at us and they say wouldn't we
love to have an economy that's booming
where people are rushing through to buy
something I mean economies around the
world are doing terribly they would kill
for this yeah that's the American Way
right like yes I consumerism at its
finest but I will say when you really do
the research these sales aren't all that
great no they're not that that's what's
crazy I'm trying tough oh great just
you're just selling the thing but I mean
come on like I'm serious yeah final
thought on this what do you make of like
just the general group mentality like
when you see those videos they're
they're funny but people literally get
trampled something I got killed could
they have walmart a couple years ago
peppers I mean all kinds of what is it
about that cuz I don't think it's just
about the deal I think there's some
other a Gretel lives yeah something else
going on I love to see it I love to see
the videos i love to see people like
rushing in and who gets it you know one
of the best things this is those bridal
Oh God when there's like a bridal sale
sale and those brides are like Russian
over people those are fantastic you
can't see another what would you do with
the right would you actually participate
or have you participated I don't know
where a wedding black friday though he's
a sound funny I was good but the black
friday stuff you know maybe if it was
the sale was right uh i would pay
somebody to wait in line for me and then
come in at the last minute that's the
way of real capitalist does it face
somebody oh that wait in line and go
from there all right well let's move on
from capitalism to some international
stuff you might have heard about this
the nuclear negotiations with iran looks
like it's moving forward a little bit
with the p5 plus one we got a deal
there's a lot to do here so i'm going to
try to break it down simply because i
feel like this is what's getting lost
everyone's just immediately like
hey it's greater that's awful so let's
let's break it down a little bit here's
what the US and the p5 plus 1 got Iran's
going to neutralize all their 20-percent
enriched uranium they can't enrich
uranium over five percent and must
dismantle equipment that can do so so
they can't build more this is
centrifuges and things like that and
they're going to get daily IAEA
inspections here's what I ran got four
point two billion in overseas assets
unfrozen 1.5 billion in sanctions lifted
and the u.s. implicitly acknowledges
Iran's right to enrich there's already a
debate about this Iran is saying that
they got the the right to enrich the
u.s. is saying not quite and we got a
little more for you here are some
reasons why it might work China and
Russia are on board so we have a bigger
international group backing this it
meets the Iranian demand for the West to
acknowledge its right to enrich and I
just said that seems to be a little up
for debate at the moment and unfreezing
of assets is tied to Iran Iranian
compliance so they have to actually do
some things to get some of these assets
back and here are some reasons why it
might not work it only lasts six month
the permanent deal might be tougher so
this could last a little bit and then
fall apart many countries most of the
neighboring countries Israel Saudi
Arabia Bahrain Qatar Kuwait the United
Arab Emirates they're all skeptical and
those are the guys that basically live
on their borders there's opposition both
in DC between the Senate the Congress
and in Tehran and it ignores non-nuclear
issues funding for terrorism they fund
Hezbollah in Lebanon their funding Assad
in Syria and all kinds of stuff okay so
it's a lot of information but that's
pretty bare-bones stuff how do you feel
about the deal in it will just start
with the general end of it look I like
the concept of diplomacy but I am
concerned I mean one of my greatest
concerns is yeah I'm all with the daily
inspections but it still doesn't sound
like real verification to me oh man I do
have very serious concerns about that
and also like you said it the last
points a big one to me it doesn't
address the non-nuclear issues which are
still very very much concerning uh you
know if that's not the only issue is the
possibility of a nuclear bomb right so
everyone's ignoring that part of it that
you know right now they have this
American hostage right now
they are they have three great okay so
there's three American hostages don't
even know about the other two three
Americans in prison okay so so they've
got three Americans in prison so we
didn't address that we didn't address
the Hezbollah issue we didn't address
arming Assad and all that so a lot of
people are saying that that's legit
we're not addressing immediate concerns
but is this sort of how negotiations
have to work that we had to give up some
stuff too well i hope i hope not there's
so much here don't even know where to
begin first of all in the three
americans in prison truth be told i work
with one trying to help amir hekmati get
out of prison okay i don't think that
this deal should ever deal with
americans in prison there are two
separate issues and we should not put
our government in the position of
negotiating for prisoners right we don't
do it we shouldn't expect others to do
it that's not a very what's the basis
for that basically because this is a
nuclear issue this is very serious
national security issues this is not
something that we want to trade
prisoners for that will encourage
someone to grab an American next time
and then we have to negotiate for that
American so I would immediately put that
aside i'm sure the family is not happy
that I'm saying that the simple fact on
this deal is though we have six un
security council resolutions already
passed that are very clear that say Iran
must stop enriching all uranium right
Russia and China are on board with that
so this agreement is not greater
international support we already had
Russian trying to us on board this
agreement is less than the UN Security
Council agreement this is weaker than
the UN when you are weaker than the UN
you've got a really big problem I don't
buy that you have to do this just for
negotiations like your point on the
daily inspections is a really good one
because it's not really daily
inspections of anywhere we want to go
its daily inspections where they tell us
to go okay so that's so that's the part
that so the try let's talk about the
trust thing here because right so they
can say yeah you can inspect this
building today or this uh heavy water
reactor today but we have stuff over
here that you can see we've already been
through this with North Korea so is part
of the excitement over the deal is that
just most people just sort of don't
understand like it sounds good all on
paper but
actually how it works other people are
excited that it that there's engagement
for the first time in 30 years I think
people are excited that there's been a
15 minute phone call and now that
there's no handshakes and embracing it
and it looks like diplomacy but I do
tend to agree with some of the things
you know both of you guys are saying
especially since Africa saying I don't
think I think we gave too much and we
got too little and and I think that's
ultimately any deal is not necessarily a
good deal a deal yes that's good that's
a step in the right direction and i
appreciate john kerry saying it's just
that a step and we've got the six months
to go further but it does feel like they
got a little more than wonder why
Hillary didn't do this deal because she
was against it really oh she's not going
to negotiate with Iran let's be very
clear about something that the media is
not telling us we have negotiated on
this for a very long time in 2006 we
started with a deal the international
community was united and what President
Obama did was undercut the entire
international community to pretend like
he got some new deal and that we're
talking with them for the first time yes
the Americans are talking with the
Iranians directly but make no mistake
we've been talking in a group for a very
long time and the world has been united
we just lessened the demand so what do
you say to the people that say we'll
just the talking is good this whole
thing that's happening on Twitter you
know I've been very vocal about how I
think the whole twitter things a
ridiculous because there it's blocked
right twitter is blocked in iran so
Ronnie and Zarif they're all tweeting to
us in English and then everyone tube
video he's putting yet doing a YouTube
video and I was like great can you open
up the Internet in Iran so that your
people can actually see your videos it's
all a farce so they keep trying all
right so they're telling us about this
charm offensive except we're the only
ones seeing it so it seems to me that if
you really were behind the people of
Iran you would be fighting at first
let's how about we just give them
Facebook and then we'll go okay well now
maybe we trust you because they don't
seem to trust their own people enough
vote but yet we should present our core
issue is whether or not they have the
right to enrich okay and already today
we heard the Iranians come out and say
we're so thankful that we have the right
to enrich when the White House is saying
no you don't and now the Iranians are
calling the White House a liar it's four
days in Dave we're already falling apart
unless agreement so I think what John
Kerry would say to that is what we can
just ratchet up the sanctions again
after six months but I don't think you
agree look a lot of people think that
they're two to three months away from
breaking out and this neutralizing their
20-percent enriched uranium is a lot of
BS because you can neutralize what we
know you have we don't know what else is
behind the curtain and if you neutralize
a little you can ramp it up pretty fast
so speaking of what we don't know I
think there's some times when we all
talk about this stuff we can only get
the information that's being
disseminated to us and look it's already
come out that they were negotiating
privately for a long time so is there a
little bit of futility in sort of the
day-to-day discussion of this stuff
unless you're sitting in the meetings
right there right and that's the part
about it that you know I want to get
behind it my emotionally it sounds
really good to me but I don't know maybe
it's the defense lawyer me I'm just
always anticipating what I don't know
what we're not seeing as a nation like
you said Dave they don't even trust
their own people so I don't know how I
can trust anything you're telling me was
what was right so what could we do to
then empower the people and not empower
the regime because no one's I haven't
heard anybody even the most people the
furthest people on the right I haven't
heard anyone say they're against the
people of Iran people want them to be
free well what we could have done is we
could have supported the Green
Revolution when they took to the streets
but instead President Obama said we're
not going to get involved so he took a
pass at supporting the people and he's
supporting the government now so i think
president mom is doing the exact
opposite what he should be doing if you
want to bifurcate the people from the
government support the people don't play
into the government's lame messaging I
mean it's just they're not a bunch of
moderates rouhani tweets and our entire
media go crazy because it's Sweeting
that I cannot believe that that everyone
retweets it like oh my god this is so
great except they can't see it it's
because they were so thirsty for the
idealism behind it yeah but I don't
wither there are some great people to
follow that our inside Tehran that are
doing you know and i'm not talking about
Thomas her bunk from the New York Times
yeah I mean I think he's terrible he's
part of the the problem but there are
people on Twitter that are really good
to follow that are inside Iran that are
giving you really unfiltered information
are ways to get around it now I'll get
some of those names and we'll put them
in the in the description so my last
thought on this is I think it's also a
little bizarre that you know countries
that don't border Iran seem pretty
thrilled about this so US and england
and france and germany and russia etc
but all the guys around them are going
this is not good I mean the fact that
Saudi Arabia and Israel suddenly seem
like allies is crazy so how do we should
we be giving a little more credence to
the neighbors that are right there I
think so because again there's there
they at least have a likelihood of
seeing a lot more truth than we're
seeing we're just too far removed from
it I agree on the the enemy of my enemy
is my friend and that's clearly what
we're seeing with Israel's I right but
and it that gives me more pause like I'm
already looking at around sideways right
you know and and now that your closest
geographical neighbors are so adamantly
a fearful and opposed to it gives me
even further pause we gotta give them
some credence on that our allies don't
trust us in our enemies don't fear us
anymore and it's a really sad commentary
on the Middle East but you know I look
at Turkey and Jordan and you know
Lebanon i think is one of the saddest
stories of the Middle East we we we
pushed the Syrians out of Lebanon to
give Lebanon a chance in the bush
administration and now the Syrians are
back in Lebanon Lebanon has fallen apart
all because of the Syria Iran problem
and now we just empowered Iran the
Lebanese are left out yeah alright so
finals have thought on this because we
can talk about this forever probably so
what would you say to the people that
would say heard everything you just said
right there and say well what's the
alternative war because that's sort of
the way it's being framed right now
either we had to take this deal or war
was coming nobody wants war but the
simple fact is you have to ask yourself
a very tough question do you want a
nuclear-armed Iran and I think you know
the president President Obama says no
everyone has said no the the reality is
the facts show they're really close to
break out six months of them pulling our
chain could be the difference of them
breaking out so sanctions are not going
to work any longer it's too late for
sanctions I think the fact of the matter
is if you don't want a nuclear
derron you're going to have to have some
sort of action the YouTube people are
not going to be happy with you know and
I know that all right let's move on so
this is actually a really big story that
broke out this week so USA Today is no
longer going to use the official White
House photographer pictures of the
president and of the first family
because they feel that this is basically
propaganda but coming from the White
House 38 news outlets agree with them
and they sent a letter to the White
House protesting they're shutting out of
independent photo journalists in favor
of taxpayer-funded photographers the
White House official photographers
name's Peter sauza so what you're seeing
on the left there that was just taken by
any old photographer and this is
obviously in washington DC at the mall
and all the photographers if you look at
the picture on the right they're all
stuck in there in that spot and they're
getting that sort of distant picture but
the official White House photographer he
gets a pretty sweet spot right behind
the president the full image and
everything else right there that's Peter
salsa on the left with his camera and
that's a that's a image from a regular
photographer who has to get him in the
picture to get the good picture of Obama
and then obviously on the right that's
the good picture of Obama and that's the
picture that then gets tweeted out by
the White House and then picked up by
all the news organizations and all that
now this one is particularly interesting
so this is the Obamas visited the cell
where Nelson Mandela was held this was
they announced that this was going to be
totally private that they were going to
be no photographs taken at all however
yes photographs were taken of course
this is done by Pete and the USA Today
their director of multimedia he issued a
statement on this the functions of the
president at the White House are
fundamentally public in nature and
should be documented for the public by
independent news organizations not
solely by the White House press office
and that's Andrew Scott from USA Today
so I think what's interesting about this
is this has always been done we can
think of pictures of every president in
modern times where they have the
official White House picture but what's
different here is that now because of
social
media once it gets tweeted out by the
official account everybody picks it up
no but a different though because the
White House this White House is barring
so they're all photographers from going
in on the Nelson Mandela visit reporters
were barred from going in they were not
allowed they were told no pictures only
to find out on Twitter a little bit
later that there were official pictures
you know who else does this Iran and
North Korea stay around me do their
absolute value I have sang about Russia
here yeah that's what they do I mean
this is outrageous but you know what if
the reporters in the White House press
corps are not going to be up in arms
about it they all want to be like sheep
and follow it you know they're looking
ridiculous but they are starting to wake
up right yeah okay here's the thing I I
think there is an issue of propaganda
and I part of my brain Toli alliance
with that but then there's another part
of my brain maybe it's the vein side
that feels like doesn't the president
and his family have a right to control
their media image in that way like if I
see a picture that I don't like of
myself on facebook i'm gonna untag it
seriously but kind of the same not
anointed by God I liked it fine i was
gonna say I know it won't happen here oh
but no and get that so the fact that
he's our president makes it different
but I understand some desire even if
it's not necessarily from bad motives I
guess is all I'm saying it might not be
that it's because I know what everyone
think it was untagging himself on
facebook that's it it's another to bar
everybody with a camera I do you guys
think there's a distinction between the
public events so let's say that event at
the mall at the MLK thing or versus
where where there can be a lot of
photographers there and they penned them
they literally put them in a pen vs uh
something private in the White House I
can understand that if he's on a phone
call uh you know with rouhani that that
can be the the official White House
because you can't bring in a zillion
photographers all that they lie live
this problem for eight years and that
reporters are never going to be happy
until they are actually inside the room
where the decision is being made the
problem is they're not saying anything
to this White House they've spent five
years allowing this White House are now
a little bit it's a little late we've
been we've been through the reelection
uh you know my problem is is that you
don't get to say that you're for
journalism and then stay quiet on this
cuz you're ruined you're ruining
journalism so I think the hypocrisy is
really taken America back in terms of
freedom of the press yeah why do you
think it's a slippery slope I'll say
that kind of contradict my previous
statement in that if it gets to this
point where there is such restriction
and banning and and I have sole control
over my media image then it does create
a lot of space for for bad things and
stuff like that does this also go to how
we were too focused on image constantly
because this White House obviously in
the advent of social media everything is
very image focused and it when I was
reading the story was reminding me of
Marco Rubio in the water bottle whatever
his rebuttal was that night nobody even
remembers but everyone remembers this
guy uncomfortably having dry mouth and
grabbing a bottle of water and that's
what was I mean CNN literally ran a
headline in this destroy his career
right so is there something about image
that maybe we're getting completely out
of control with instead of substance
yeah I mean yeah yeah obviously yeah I
mean that's the thing and that's um I
think we've got to decide where we want
to place that moving forward this is not
new we've seen this gradually happening
for years now and I just think because
of social media it's just now at an
all-time high and we are we're visually
stimulated and engaging and it's been
something that the Obama administration
has benefited from greatly but you know
I it's not just going to always be the
Obama administration in the White House
um so we have to think about where
that's going to lead people moving for i
don't i'm not surprised that politicians
are trying to control their image or are
worried about you know what the public
thinks of them that's absolutely normal
I think it's organic I also think that
the Obama team is not totally to blame
for wanting to control that and taking
taking it to the next level from what
the Bush administration did the next
administration is going to be even worse
however with that being said they're
absolutely needs to be a check and
balance from the media from the White
House press corps to say no and what
they did is for five years they allowed
this creep and I mean the creeping of
the
process Jake or no no I mean this slow
creep yeah of having their rights
completely taken away from them now they
are concerned now they are saying things
like wait a minute you're doing
interviews with you know celebrity-type
magazines and not sit downs with real
journalists and and they've made this
bed and they've ruined the journalistic
process in while doing it right that's a
slight off topic but i really like that
so is there anything they can do to
change that because even now when i
watch presidential press conferences you
know he's got three people that he asks
questions to and then he answers
questions for so long that they never
ask more questions because nobody even
knows what how it started but also they
purposely set it up so that he asks
questions of people that aren't gonna
and ask important questions and follow
ups and things like that is there
anything we can do at this point are we
sort of down that rabbit hole now is
that too far yeah I mean I do I like the
checks and balances thing I think
ideally here's what would work best but
it might be too late uh you can have
your own designated official stuff that
you have control over and you present
yourself and your family the way you
want to and also have independent
objective journalists do their job so
that America feels like there's a
there's some diversity there but I agree
maybe it's too late for that now so in
terms of the photos couldn't you have
the official White House photographer
just with everyone and it's still an
official white house photo what was
happening in the bush administration
look I i think that the daily White
House briefings and the the press
conferences from president united states
you're not going to get real information
there that's all for show and it's
gotten worse and it's and it's never
going to be the situation where we're
going to get real information
journalists need to do their job they
need to investigate they need to go to
the different cabinet officials they
need to dig down so that we can get the
truth yeah I don't expect the President
United States to know every detail of
what's going on so at a press conference
I want him or her to give me the the
kind of overall strategy I'll get the
details from someone else yeah all right
well despite the photo propaganda and
all that the numbers are not looking
that great for President Obama actually
a new CNN Oh RC poll indicates that for
the first time ever he's scoring low
basically a
us the board on all the polls forty
percent of americans now believe the
president obama can manage the federal
government effectively which is down
twelve percent from june fifty three
percent of americans believe that Obama
is not honest and trustworthy so that's
huge right there fifty-three percent
don't view him as strong and decisive
leader fifty-six percent say he's not a
person they admire that also seems
incredibly high fifty-six percent say he
does not agree with them on important
issues fifty-six percent say he does not
inspire confidence there's something
about the 56 number here I think but
then there's a couple things that are ok
and this six in 10 say he has a vision
for the country's future and seven in 10
say he's likeable so I know there's a
lot of numbers there but basically this
is looking kind of bad is this just sort
of second term lame duck like you've
hung around for a while and now people
turn on but I have to say that um that
tends to be the case date but we also
know people like Clinton Reagan will
ended up being actually a little more
popular in their second term and some
polling this is the thing the president
has been too concerned with trying to be
right particularly we will just take the
issue the one anyone talk about with
Obamacare keep like your plan keep your
plan here's an opportunity to say am I
going to try to stay being right or am I
going to be trustworthy and truthful I
think it would have been better played
to say I was wrong on this I am wrong on
this I apologize for this this that way
you put it we're going to fix it and I'm
going to do with everything I can to
make sure that this is what it is that
would preserve credibility what he did
was he sacrificed credibility and
trustworthiness to try to be right and
that was wrong I don't think that
there's anyone in the White House it's
really giving him honest assessments I
mean let's face it the excuse coming
from the president is usually I didn't
know or some other lame excuse and I
don't what do you mean you don't know
you fire that advisor who was supposed
to tell you right because if they're
holding something back from you either
they have a huge ego or you instructed
them to keep things from you either way
that's a bad process I think a lot of
this is second term problems typical of
what every president goes through I
think Obamacare right now is highly
toxic it's not going to get fixed I
think politicians are going to be
running from this so a lot of these
numbers are reflective of that I still
think he can come back if he if he does
some of the moments of I wish I would
have done better or been more so you
think the the apology that he did give
cuz he basically said sorry about
Obamacare but you think it was too late
and he and he did sort of skirt now yeah
it was like a Canino that annoying
apology you get for my friend right I'm
sorry that you are offended by what i
said that's BS right right just own it
and I think people are more forgiving of
that than they are for feeling like you
know you're still skirting the issue and
i agree with you i think his advisors
are echo chambers they're just get
really feeding back to him what they
think he wants to hear and we don't have
time for that as anybody that supports
the president generally speaking and I
do it's frustrating I'll also say this
this is just my thing just between us
just between us guys um the president we
all know comes from a legal background
right and one of the things we do is try
well okay no no to my point to my point
right professor background exactly see
I'm a trial lawyer and one of the things
we do is when our back is against the
wall we come out fighting harder I hate
the posture and and the presentation of
this president in most recent press
conferences slouched down you look
defeated stand up be bold in your
assertions of where you have gone wrong
and how you're going to write this
course that is something that I would
like to see from him and you're right
they're like we're I know he's the same
let's go have a group meeting at
starbucks and we'll talk this out yeah i
mean that's what you do in a classroom
setting you have more group meetings and
you you talk where's the advocacy this
is a time for him to be an advocate for
the American people in a strong way even
though you've screwed up in some areas
and I think even he knows that in his
kind of acknowledged it you got to
acknowledge those screw-ups strongly I'm
sorry that you trusted me it was really
as apology right so he's a part of this
though that he it's very obvious that he
likes to be like you know a lot of
people say that like Bill Clinton like
to be in the room negotiating the deal
and that it seems clear that President
Obama he is that he has this big picture
thing but he doesn't really want to sit
down with everybody and negotiate all
the deals so then it goes to what you're
saying before about how
we don't really know how much he
actually knows about what's happening I
think there are other things that
Clinton like I'm not just being in the
room that's the my first point but I i
I'm not like I couldn't get out of that
without dr. Clinton okay I'm not
surprised that any politician wants to
be liked I think there's a lot of
politicians on the right that loved to
be liked and are crippled by decisions
because of that but there's no question
that this president to me is sheltered
he's got bad advisers who don't give him
the real information and he's really
inexperienced he was a try he was a
professor not someone who ever made
decisions and let's face it as a
community organizer he was a really
lousy one he never finished the job he
was on to the next one promoted before
he ever really finished the job same
thing in the Senate so I don't think
he's ever been through something to see
it true I have agree with that because
again I do think he's a personally
believe he's a great visionary and we
even see numbers they're still support
that people believe he has a vision his
follow through implementation and
ability to enforce logistics is a place
where he is faltered and this is a place
where if you know that's in here's my
thing my mom always raised me when you
know your weaknesses and this is a place
why halfway when a credit george w bush
when you know what you would listen just
kavya here but when you know what you
don't do well that is your opportunity
to surround recruit and enable yourself
with people that do it exceptionally
well and i would like to see more of it
i think this is one of the republicans
problems too is is that we have been
attacking his vision which his vision is
one of those things that's like you know
everyone should be a part of do you want
people to have health care everyone yes
right you want world peace yes I mean
diploma give diplomacy a chance yes
we've done that the problem is is that
the devil is in the details with him is
because we have tried diplomacy we we
need health care insurance reform that
health care reform you know there are a
lot of these issues that the Republicans
have been terrible at because we've
attacked the vision we need to attack
his in competence well I agree and
that's the thing with Obamacare it's a
frustration for it you know the left we
love the vision to obviously but you've
got all the effort and passion we saw
from the president when he can
on selling this concept to the American
people and to his constituents now we
want to see that same passion I want to
see in the details and the logistics
like how do you get this thing passed a
supreme court challenge but the website
doesn't work like that's crazy and we
keep taking nails card Roberts right or
or we just keep taking parts of the law
and it's still it's still going forward
which is there's debate where that's
even constitutional uh but is another
something working to his advantage here
that there's still no Republicans that
anybody likes I mean you got chris
Christie sort of so it's just like our
bounce back even though we're still
years away from the election there's
just like a general feeling of like well
what I'll turn it they're not going to
do any better you have a bunch of
Republicans that I like what give me a
give me three give you three that you
think it could be electable generally
well first of all scott walker has
already demonstrated that he's won twice
in a democratic state the guy is a great
guy a nice guy who's got a great vision
and knows how to implement it was either
changes that he's on the national stage
yes he's a little bit but most people I
there he's been tried by the national
media already they tried to bring him
down they didn't I think I think you
need to watch him i also like governor
Sandoval in Nevada I think he's a one to
watch and Governor Snyder in Michigan a
great guy who's really been able to kind
of make fundamental changes I think you
got to watch those I'm all for governor
i think i would i would always say we
should never elect another senator ever
again I know Rand Paul for you you know
I he's not my choice I don't like his
foreign policy vision I'm a little
concerned about that I I'll I think
there are other governors that are
better I'm a pleasure to Rand Paul's
opposition to the civil rights act
that's just why I stand on it I'd like
to put that out there no I do agree i
like seeing a present who has had
executive leadership experience which is
more or less what we see or something
more than yes yes exactly where you're
actually in charge of something for real
so I do think in implementing and seeing
it through and chiefly responsible for
its implementation which is why I like a
governor going to the president just
presidency as well um but I do i do
agree i feel like this is an opportunity
for the GOP to maximize and we'll have
to wait and see if they do that you know
got to come up with a better alternative
we
well alright well let's bring this thing
home talking about anger because America
is very angry the holiday season is here
but people are pissed a new study from
USA Today found out that sixty percent
of americans report feeling angry or
irritable which is up from fifty percent
when a similar poll was done 2011 I
really don't understand this because
every commercial you see on TV is for
antidepressants so they're obviously not
working uh you know and there's all
kinds of public people that are in in
this anger fit constantly between Alec
Baldwin and Chris Brown and all you know
all these endless people screaming about
everything and you know people are
saying that the anger epidemic could be
because of the economy and people are
upset about work and money and all that
and just the political gridlock do you
think America is angrier than it used to
be America's spoiled am i doing I think
America's spoiled I think America feels
a bit entitled I can speak for my
generation particularly um a lot of if
there is a lot of entitlement and that's
where a lot of anger is for coming from
it's like no you need to look at
yourself and you to hold yourself a
little bit more personally accountable
and I think some of that anger and I
like I'll take this for example I had a
pretty rough day the other day and in
those moments that's where you turn to
gratitude and you actually just turn it
all the way around and you'd be grateful
for what you do have and then you get a
game plan and strategy together but what
we know is Chris Brown's not angry
because he doesn't have money so you
know that's that I'm sure hopefully by
alligator also drag Josh Brolin the
other knob broke by the way I was Alden
who lost his job at MSNBC this week he
still makes 15 million dollars a year
capital one so he'll be okay you know I
think people have always been angry i
mean you talk to your parents and they
always talk about the negative people
that were in their life the problem is
that they just didn't have twitter back
then tell you on a daily basis how angry
i am and about every little situation or
on TV or 24 hour news networks i mean
when you were angry back in the 80s you
didn't make the nightly news right now
when you're angry we've got four
networks with 24-hour news coverage and
youtube to make sure that you know who's
angry i think people are probably
exactly the way that they've always been
we just know about it all right what
people always say we're more violent
than ever but then it's like you know
they're there to say
pretty sure people walking with an ax
just hack a number so that that's not
true yeah uh so the social media part I
think is kind interesting cuz yeah we
can get caught up in all the anger all
the time and all that but I think there
is something very comforting about
social media to that if something bad
happens is there's a shooting or
something that or the terrorist attack
in Boston let's say that we have some
ability to share like an experience yeah
and to know your neighbors coffee choice
in the morning really important to know
see their Instagram day yes I have to
immediately go and see what kind of eggs
your chose yeah well you know another
thing though the social media does that
I don't like is it encourages a lot of
people to do this stupid comparing thing
you know where maybe I if I feel might
wake up feeling okay about your life and
then I look at your timeline or your
newsfeed and now I'm pissed you know and
that's it's so silly I hate that about
it but that really to me is like a
Instagram thing because everything looks
so much better on Instagram so you wake
up and you go oh my friend had a glass
of wine last night but that looks that
looks better than I mind as I press that
little button yeah I don't think I was
talking about a second ago like stop it
you know let's just really take a moment
and really like get this together why
the Thanksgiving talking points work
because people want to just follow
somebody yeah so go bring in this full
circle yeah what about anger at the
holidays then how how do you deal with
you know if you get into a big debate do
you just let it go or do you really
bring it home well the problem is a lot
of festivities are fueled by alcohol and
uh oh you're really belly the problem
it's a good thing but no one I think
people just kind of had that stuff pent
up and then after you know by the time
you get to nighttime at the house it's
just all it's all fair game yeah I think
house we always talk politics I always
oh yeah i mean my house to me and my mom
we go back and forth and that's that's
our thing so speaking of politics how
much of this just the general anger
thing has to do with politics because of
all the cable news stuff and it's why
I'm trying to do this show so that's not
just screaming at each other but if you
look at something like crossfire which i
think is the like prototypical example
of this thing I'm on the right I'm on
the left and that we live in this
constant battle so how much just general
is because people just hear messages
that are fighting with each other all
time and we never stop and say actually
most of what we're doing here is and
people buy into it what's crazy to me is
when I'm on any other cable news show
and and I actually deviate from this
strong left or strong right and I get to
a point of considered uh like people
don't know what to do with it and it's
like and people from the outside of some
of the sheep they're so tied to these
talking points themselves and being fed
them that they almost resent or don't
know how to react when you deviate from
that yeah I mean that you're preaching
to the choir yeah people like it I guess
that is the beauty of the internet and I
suddenly feel very good about everything
i'm doing ebony yeah and I'm thankful
for you guys i want to thank ebony k
williams Rick Grinnell also known as
Richard Grinnell on Twitter their
twitters are right down below hope you
guys enjoyed your turkey day and we will
do this next week barring some sort of
anger episode that requires me to take
the week off but I don't think so
alright thanks